У Німеччині після нещодавнього "вихлопного" скандалу
невпинно падає попит на нові та вживані дизельні машини.
Тоді з'ясувалося, що концерн "Фольксваген"
довгий час маніпулював показниками шкідливих викидів.
А от і новий удар:
купувати дизельні автомобілі вже не рекомендує навіть
німецький автомобільний клуб ADAC,
який має в Німеччині великий авторитет.
Автомобілі з таким екологічним стандартом
мають відповідати нормам не лише
в лабораторних умовах, а й під час звичайних поїздок.
Німецькі автоконцерни, які інвестували
мільярди євро в розвиток дизельних технологій,
вказують на вищу енергоємність дизельного палива
і, відповідно, меншу кількість викидів.
Натомість критики дизеля переконують:
канцерогенні часточки й отруйний діоксид азоту
від дизельних двигунів
особливо небезпечні для людини. Тому лунають заклики
обмежити або навіть заборонити використання дизелю.
Все частіше й сама влада німецьких міст
порушує питання про заборону на в'їзд дизельним машинам.
Першим, як не дивно, стало
найавтомобільніше місто Німеччини - Штутгарт,
столиця автопрому, батьківщина таких автовиробників,
як Даймлер і Порше.
Услід за Штутгартом непроханими гостями
дизельні машини можуть стати у Гамбурзі та Мюнхені.
Я зобов'язаний повідомити вам,
що в Мюнхені рівень небезпечного діоксиду азоту
в повітрі перевищує норму.
Моє завдання як обер-бургомістра -
зробити все можливе для гарантування здоров'я жителів Мюнхена.
Потрібно робити все можливе, щоб цього досягти.
Майбутні заборони, судячи з усього,
і стали головною причиною,
чому дедалі більше як приватних осіб, так і німецьких фірм
нині утримуються від придбання
дизельних автомобілів. І хоча у впливовому
німецькому автоклубі ADAC
дизель остаточно не списують з рахунків, а просто радять чекати нових моделей, які відповідають стандарту Євро-6,
багато експертів налаштовані скептично.
Центр автомобільних досліджень університету Дуйсбург-Ессена
протестував понад 80 моделей авто
з дизельними двигунами. У лабораторних умовах їх
показники були справді прийнятними. Однак
при тестуванні на вулиці рівень забруднення
збільшувався в шість разів.
І лише 6 із 83 дизельних автомобілів
повністю відповідали екологічним вимогам.